how bad do you want it what's the price
you are willing to pay if you are
spending your time doing work that you
hate you will never win you can become
anything you want to be but life is
gonna ask you one simple question what
price are you willing to pay to get
there
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right to get there grab your coffee
and sip on today's message pay the price
over to you Dan lock also if you want to
know what Dan lock and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below after you practice
Marshall you develop this natural self
confidence not cockiness but you develop
this natural self-confidence
[Music]
I remember the first five years when I
was building my empire building my
business that first five years I was
working I did not take a single day off
for five years strict I was working
every single day 12 to 14 hours I
remember there were nights where I
actually literally worked till
exhaustion and I fell asleep in four on
my desk that's the price that I pay
while all my friends they were drinking
partying watching sports gaming and then
chasing girls I didn't do any of that I
was focused I was obsessed because I was
willing to pay for the price for success
I was committed to spend a few years
doing whatever it takes doing things
that other people are not willing to do
making sacrifices that other people are
not willing to make so that I could do
what I want to do for the rest of my
life what about you how bad do you want
it what's the price you are willing to
pay if you are thinking about how many
hours you're working and you're
frustrated and you're complaining I
think you've lost like I think if you
are counting down as an entrepreneur how
many more hours to go until the day is
over until you get to go on your
vacation until you know the weekend is
here I think you've lost like I
genuinely think you've lost you have to
love the work if you look at look at all
of the people that I've done profiles on
across entrepreneurship athletics
singing everybody they love the work you
have to love the process not just the
results it's why you have to love it so
much to put through all the crap all the
negativity all the burnout all of the
stuff that happens to you as an
entrepreneur you have to deal with it
and the only thing that gets you through
is you love it I love making videos I'm
here in Albuquerque
Nina's getting her nails done Danny's
getting his chairs phone charged in the
car and I'm making videos cuz I love
making videos because I can't wait to
make videos I've done 6000 plus videos
on my channel and I can't wait to make
more I love it I love the process I love
helping entrepreneurs
I love the
and a little process and yes that can
cause personal issues that can cause
health breakdowns that can cause you to
get stressed out that can cause you to
push beyond your limits that can cause
you how issues they can relationship
issues they can and the does for so many
entrepreneurs and yes you need to guard
for that you need to watch for that you
need to be able to create an intentional
life not just working working working
working working working all the time and
then you die but you need to love the
work you need to love the process it's
not painful to do it same pay the price
it's not painful to pay the price for
you separate into my schedule making six
thousand videos you might think is
really painful for me it's not like I
love it it's great it's amazing and that
should be the same thing in your
business people who say it's a will do
whatever it takes going wrong you won't
do whatever it takes because as soon as
it starts getting really hard you're
gonna quit where somebody who actually
loves that thing will keep going because
they love it and you don't and whenever
you're up against somebody who loves to
work and you don't they will destroy you
even if you have more natural talent
they will destroy you because they love
the work and you don't that makes all
the difference in the world and so you
gotta go find the thing that you love
you gotta find the things that other
people would find torture Jerry Seinfeld
calls it the torture you can endure it
should be torture somebody else should
step into your schedule feel like it's
torture but for you you love it it
brings you up and makes you come alive
you love doing that work now before you
start thinking this is a recipe for
burnout disaster and it is for a lot of
people you need to have an intentional
life I believe you need to have an
intentional life so what if an ideal
life look like for you where you're
doing work that you enjoy where you're
spending time with your husband or wife
or kids or parents or friends whatever
you need out of life sit down and create
a calendar create your calendar from
Sunday to Sunday and chunk your time and
block off time to say this is my work
time and this is my time with my family
and this is my time doing my hobbies and
this is my time with my wife and this is
my time with my kids and I'm not here to
judge how much time you want to spend
with your kids versus your wife versus
your business versus your parents and
that'll shift as your priorities change
as you get older and life happens and
that's okay what I'm saying is for the
time that you're working if it's 20
hours a week if it's 40 hours a week if
it's a hundred hours a week whatever
time you're
you're spending on your business you
need to be doing work that net you love
you may not love every single second of
every single day you may have to do a
lot of work that you don't enjoy but net
overall you love the process if you are
sitting here looking at your work
looking at your business looking at your
schedule and dreading what's coming up
and counting down the hours until the
weekend you've already lost get out of
that business and go find something else
because if you are spending your time
doing work that you hate you will never
win and you have Michael Jordan level
talent as something and you need to find
it embrace it and use it to change the
world for the better now I've got a
really special bonus skip that I think
you're going to enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know deep
love the process of your business do you
love it do you love it love it let me
know let me feel your energy
put it in the comments below and if
you're not feeling it be honest that's
amazing that self-awareness is gonna
kick you up to the next level let me
know in the comments whatever your skill
set is now whatever your vision of
yourself is now you can change it you
can become anything you want to be but
life is gonna ask you one simple
question what price are you willing to
pay to get there and that's it that's
the hard truth if you're willing to pay
the price and you can become whatever
you want you can become truly capable of
the extraordinary but you've got to go
through the process of building that
skill set you've got to be willing to
stare naked Liat your inadequacies to
understand that you aren't yet the
person that you want to be or need to be
to execute against your goals but that
you can become that person and then
start walking down that path and day by
day brick by brick build the skill set
that you want when you start getting out
oh god this is stupid
these cars that you're seeing people buy
I think 50 cent got sick seven for
Christmas of stuff I got my wife of
Cullinan and I got myself this this is
ridiculous
you don't need to go out and buy these
cars okay this is without a doubt
complete waste of money and unlike
unlike some of the people that are out
buying because there's a lot of young
kids right now thinking oh I'm a go buy
a Lambo I'm gonna get a Ferrari I'm
gonna go buy me a rose I've watched a
twenty four-year-old kid by rolls-royce
I'm like man I don't even look good on
you even if you can't afford it clearly
ridiculous but years 35 years of hard
work not just hard work but making good
decisions and putting the money away
putting the money away and not doing
this kind of stuff put all this stuff
off don't do this right now okay pay the
price right now work hard get great at
your job get great at whatever you do so
good that people are like man you're the
best well who are you what do you want
they start asking questions about wow
what makes you so unique then you're
gonna start getting paid more there's no
way on this planet that if people don't
if people start talking about how
exceptional you are you will get paid
more at some point when you do take that
money and invest it in something where
you can't lose it where it pays you
every month and one day in the future
it'll be worth more than it is today
do that for years it might take 10 years
15 years 20 years I'm just starting to
enjoy my life hard Bert man hi this is
Dan Locke if you're a fan of Evans work
if you want to know exactly how the
model my success I want to invite you to
join me for a special online training
all you have to do is click on a link
below you can join me for absolutely no
charge so click a link below and I will
see you in class
and if you want more day in law check
out the top 50 rules video my 10 10 the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there The [ __ ] to chase
them on I want to make the money I want
to make the money then you can see these
people they're so desperate they don't
make money you don't make money